foreign
Lagos promising Smiles are asking to be
chosen
a new Administration is forming that
will govern the country for the next
four years
but Africa's largest population is
preoccupied with personal matters here
on a single Road in the economic capital
bustling banks are the bad kind of busy
we're on one of the main streets in
Lagos and all along this road are crowds
of people standing outside of banks
waiting to get their hands on some cash
people are angry
unable to access their own funds to buy
Basic Essentials
before eight o'clock from eight o'clock
not until now you never see anything to
collect I'm not going to go to anybody
I'm not going to put for anybody at all
I'm putting to my goal
the facts
the cash shortage comes after currency
redesign policy was introduced by
incumbent president muhammadu buhari
said to combat illicit cash flows and
vote buying Central Bank is trying to
control the money and circulation
because they feel they have too much
cash outside of the banking system you
don't have
um like what you have in the UK where
people would use cards to pay it's cash
based so people can't
get to the offices people can't
pay for things in the markets because
typically you go to the market to buy
ingredients and it's still all cash
based once again
and so the hustle of everyday life has
become even harder we've been the
citizen of this country are tired
we are tired I will lie to you everybody
is just tired of this country
the despair is driving a rift between
the people and their potential new
leadership we have governments we have
politicians but all most of them like
how should I put they're just tips they
don't want to spend money they don't
they don't want to spend money on that
you they just want to spend money only
on them so
but the hope is that this discontent has
pushed Nigerians to the polls rather
than away from them I need to import
it's not actually Anna urge all
Nigerians to actually vote is is
necessary so civic duty not for yourself
but for your generations to come
more than 93 million people have
registered to vote
and those that cast their ballots to
filling their civic duty are banking on
Nigeria's new rulers to fulfill theirs
and bring about some much needed change
Sky News Lagos